hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back so let's play the curse
of Blackwater okay I'm out here and not
in the game because you all know why
because what happened to the last of it
yeah alright let's just get back into it
so we're in the sewers now and we need
to slide this sewers to stop some evil
portal dimensional rift yeah yeah the
other then I don't know but either way
we need water my god what the hell is
going on here
what the hell well okay I've got a bug
of some sort and let's try rebooting
that sumbitch broke in the game okay
alright um whoops okay my bad let's try
a level select cuz there should be just
at the start of the lorry
oh not in the sewers yet oh okay I
wouldn't even want to play this game on
any harder difficulty so I don't even
know why that's an option probably
everything's insta cool
come on come on descent oh I need to
access the sewers where I can seal the
portal hopefully the door will keep the
monstrosity at bay I've totally
forgotten why I'm here in the first
place
why did oh I'm a paranormal investigator
that's right okay I can see it's
beautiful well not really but you know
what I mean it's it's acceptable I think
okay this looks like a bunch of area to
run away from a monster which somebody
told me that there's a new monster and
that he will war the meet key our I
don't have my meet key dammit I usually
carry so much meat with me you know how
I love my meat okay so that guy's gonna
bust in eventually and supposedly he's
gonna keep chasing me until I die in
natural death I think that sound was him
breaking in was it not what most out him
there we go that's the sound whoa whoa
oh hello well ain't you interesting are
you the portal are you here to spawn
monstrosity x' I need some batteries cuz
I only got one left
okay don't want to go down there cuz
that's where he is well I see you down
there
haha he's stalking way down there now so
that means I can go in here whoa whoa
the debris needs to be cleared which
means I probably need some dynamite some
dynamite with which to blow up some
debris libris okay anything come on give
me a battery need a battery store um I
don't have that key I thought I'd picked
up a storeroom key but I guess I'm not
alright so anyway there's lots and lots
of rooms here I'm gonna die most
definitely chemical storage key number
one wait do I need three keys for that
storage because I think I remember
seeing three lights crap
where's our gay bashing down some doors
at Bravo
okay don't go that way do not
all right we're good I think what the
hell yeah it's perfect I'm still gonna
run out of batteries very soon but hey
what is this lever do you tune I don't
know what that did did that do something
important or did I just do myself to a
horrible death probably that one ladder
okay all right okay hopefully there's
another storage locker
dammit I'm gonna die chemical storage
key number three okay I just need to
find key number two and I should be able
to get its battery that looks like a
battery it'll look like batteries but
they're not okay there's something over
here a storeroom
ah-ha-ha-ha okay I'm I need to replace
the batteries soon I'm gonna hold off as
long as humanly possible and I'm gonna
hold off as long as humanly possible
then I'm gonna die that horrible death
that I was mentioning earlier that
that's gonna happen he's gonna rip out
my niblets right through my mouth pull
my nards through my mouth and then play
me like an accordion all right
battery okay I hear him I think he's
right around the corner so don't go that
way try to go this way man this place is
a freaking maze I'm never gonna be able
to find anything don't these look like
batteries these sumbitches
I swear good thing uh ha ha ha ha
finally Jesus chunk of meat all right
there's the meat key that I need for the
other thing any more batteries more
batteries no fine jeez
screw you too oh you know what I think
happened is I had more batteries before
but an to Bri I had to I didn't get to
restart my level cuz it was blogging out
ergo I had to do it stupidly hey I
didn't know I had that key I don't even
know what keys I have I do I got a
crowbar I can open that thing over there
was that somebody tried to climb to the
ceiling today oh I see that's like a
fort
hey somebody in there somebody in that
oh okay he's right around the crease
somewhere he's just a son of a [ __ ]
that's what he is
okay didn't I need the crowbar for
something in here haha I don't know I'm
celebrating and got hurt pretty bad so
anyway I need to go back to that storage
room because that's where I need the
crowbar crowbar here or crowbars up the
tower
yeah reactive chemical number one right
coming with you ditto on the plane yeah
baby
Arnie's bashing down doors over there I
need to keep going this way because this
is the area that I have not seen already
ergo I need to go this way
there's a whole lot of place here the
lower Labs is son of a [ __ ] big it's a
[ __ ] big you down there can barely
see cuz battery you know bad we Madison
I could use that I guess I see I do kind
of heal over time I have noticed at
least the blood clears out of my
eyeballs enough so that I can see a
little bit but I've got one reactive
chemical and another storage key there
was another storage door over here with
the one with lights on it this one we
can get in here
damnit okay
yeah I don't know what are you looking
at me for I don't know what I'm doing
I'm just a stupid video gamer de bris
close it are uber not in there that's
bad
oh crap I'm so Bob I'm so I'm boned do I
go what do i do where do I go what do I
do
stop following me bro this way right
here little or no door to close
can't see please thank you oh there was
another switch Raj I didn't see that
switch before it's good to see anything
okay oh crap look huh what around a
circle gonna flow throughout got flooded
heavily it's hardly fair
son of a [ __ ] oh I may open this now no
I'm cellphone he just it he's not
stopping
is this the monster that was not
stopping because although he's coming oh
he's on his way where's my meat door me
lunch crap eat the meat
did you eat the man you didn't need to
me hey my mate yeah fudgesicle you do
not take long to break down the door
that is not fair it's not fair
you're a son of a [ __ ] and hide you're
gonna never fly me daddy found me oh
this is a dead end
oh my god no
I died
try this game it's time less stupidly
we're gonna sprint we're gonna sprint
because we need we need to find things
real quickly throw this switch whatever
it does I don't know don't care
near or go near or find whatever I need
there's another battery good for me do
this where I found it before chunk of
meat got that nail in it nailing it
doing good just need to not let him find
me that's the main thing cuz if I I can
hide from him but when he starts chasing
me I'm kind of on the forever picked up
another battery how many have I missed
just because I couldn't see another
battery thank you for giving me the
batteries now not before when I needed
them don't have that see it was one key
that I found in the other area but that
was pretty much the only key I saw over
there oh okay he's in son of a [ __ ] has
landed don't have a storage key dammit I
don't remember where I found this
storage keys I don't remember where I
have a silver things can you tell me
please sir what these switches are for
that's two now two that I have switched
and I'm willing about that there's a
third one someone is Oh does it have to
do with these lights there are two
lights on I think can't quite tell hard
to tell
oh these are coming he's a-comin
quick okay I just need to stay oh I got
another battery how many of these
batteries did I miss okay chemical
storage key number one I think that's to
the area across the hall hopefully which
means I will soon be able to get into
this storeroom okay I just need to be
very cautious that's the main thing just
be cautious and I will survive
okay also I'm not gonna open doors that
I don't need to open cuz that is bad
news bears cause if I can fudge where
was the I I remember I found a crowbar
before didn't I
I did I did you can't tell me I did not
cuz I did can't tell me I didn't because
I did it was over soren I thought it was
over here in this room but I already
looked in here
no crowbar okay I hear him does that me
I just get a Facebook thing okay it must
have been in that room but I don't the
key to that room I think I got the key
to that and the other side okay
I don't hear him he must be kind of far
away no he's really close to God where
is he where is he where is he okay I
gotta get to the other side that's what
I gotta do it now
oh how is that fair that's not fair he
just there isn't even any music playing
son of a [ __ ] stop it stop it stop it
you're such an a-hole dammit try another
how I got fair I just coming stabbing me
oh no with your long arm okay whatever
ahh
alright I'm gonna plan this better for
next time I'm gonna stop it here because
it's quite a time investment for this
room so I need to get this all in one
episode and be able to do it perfectly
one time I've been good so far
like I've been lucky a past few episodes
I've been able to get thrown in a one
pretty easily but this one takes some
strategy and the guy not being an
[ __ ] and being right around the
corner when he sounded like he was down
the hall anyway thank you all so much
for watching click the entities in the
more videos it I've done and as always I
will see you in the next video
oh hi
I love that